if you're only eating sugar you're not
getting the vitamins you're not getting
the minerals you're not getting the
essential fatty acids that you need
you're not getting the protein that you
need
um we could debate whether or not you
need fiber in the diet but we probably
won't go there at the moment um
so i'm going to guess that within a
reasonably short time you're going to
die the question is can you survive
30 days
[Music]
so pete would you be considered a sweet
tooth
would i consider myself a sweet tooth
well um
i would say a little bit of i would say
yes and no i'm not one of those guys
where you
after dinner they're like hey what's for
dessert yeah yeah or i would never
order a dessert and if somebody offered
me cake or sweets or whatever i probably
wouldn't take it but if there's a bowl
of candy
on the table or if i'm in a store where
there's chocolate bars
i'm i'm i just can't get enough
chocolate yeah i've never been known for
my self-discipline that wouldn't
be something that would be on my uh
wikipedia page if i had one
uh i've been known to i have my
kryptonites so
you know i've been known to eat a
cheesecake for instance
a a cheesecake a whole cheesecake a
slice or you mean a slice
you you heard my answer but
obviously we deal with hypotheticals
here what if
and it does sound initially when you say
what if you ate only sugar for a month
well that's a wild hypothetical except
for the period where now which is gonna
smack dab in the middle of that time
where it's very possible for people to
eat sugar every day
which is of course the holidays yeah
this is when everybody is buying extra
chocolate to put on the tables to hand
out people are coming to your door
here's just here's some chocolate
there's baked goods coming out of the
oven seemingly every half hour and bowls
of candy on every
it's kind of a great thing it's a
built-in excuse
which we love so as a public service
that
we are doing for the what if community
we thought we would ask
what if you ate only sugar for a month
and of course that isn't something that
most people would have a lot of
knowledge about and
you would really want to talk to
somebody who's really done a lot of
research around the specific issue of
sugar
so we are very fortunate to be joined by
the new york times best-selling author
of the case against sugar gary taubs
gary thanks for joining us today on what
if discussed yeah
gentlemen thank you for having me so
uh as we talked about pros and cons of a
30-day sugar diet
i'm going to guess the doll out of pros
we'll get to that in a second
but let's get back to the seminal book
the case against sugar
what was your ultimate conclusion was
sugar
guilty well you i mean why write the
book if you don't think so
um and i cop to that in the beginning
the argument
i'm making in the book so i i mean we've
never
had a period of our history where you
know for instance parents didn't think
they had a race in their
their children's sugar consumption right
so it's always
there's always been this concept of too
much sugar has always been out there but
what does too much sugar
do it was a question and
what i'm addressing particularly is we
have epidemics of obesity and diabetes
worldwide whenever
any population in the world transition
from
whatever their traditional diet is it
could be anything from an agrarian diet
in
southeast asia to a animal diet with the
inuit
and the you know messiah in africa and
they transition to eating western diets
they get obese and diabetic
you have explosions of obesity and
diabetes
and the argument is that what happens is
they just eat too much and they become
sedentary and that's why you get these
epidemics and the counter argument is
that it's sugar
particularly that causes it not because
of the calories in the sugar but because
of the
uh you could think of it as a hormonal
effects of consuming sugar the way your
body responds to sugar differently than
other
foods and
you know i just was lucky as a
journalist or unlucky as a journalist i
get to spend
about 10 years of my life studying this
question
and it's clear that sugar should be
considered
uniquely harmful and the way i put it if
i was a district attorney i could get an
indictment
effortlessly i'm not sure i could get a
conviction because we've never actually
done the studies that would allow you to
say what i believe without
you know with without reasonable doubt
well yeah like you like you say it does
seem to be a bit of an open and shut
case but if the jury
is still out on sugar it's ultimately
because of the inability to get
more than circumstantial evidence
against the sweet stuff
why is that well the conventional wisdom
again is that the problem with sugars we
just eat too much of it
to empty calories you've all heard that
phrase right it's got empty calories so
if you have a lot of sugar in your diet
you have to get the vitamins and
minerals and protein and fiber
and essential fatty acids from other
foods
so then you can overeat those and you're
going to get obese and once you get
obese that's going to
you know be the trigger of your of
diabetes
so there's this whole mindset in the
book i refer to it as the gift that
keeps on giving which is the reason you
get
fat is because you eat too much you take
in more calories and you expend
and the worse you could say about sugar
is that we like it too much
we're going to take a quick break here
on what if discussed
uh more with the author of the case
against sugar
gary taubs on the other side you are
watching and listening to
what if discussed we want to take just a
moment to tell you about today's sponsor
the great courses plus a streaming
service we're both really big on
yeah that's right we've been watching
and learning a lot during the pandemic
i've been looking into a new course
they've got online called mathematical
brain teasers
and logic puzzles you know i love
learning about other languages or like
you know about ireland or photography
was another one that i did but
also sometimes i just want to stretch my
brain out and and
i don't know just go for a workout on my
brain yeah good the old brain workout
i'm a big puzzle person love the jumbo
love the crossword
sudoku no not so much why not it's just
i'm not a math person
it's not math it's just it's wonderful
i'm not a smart person
i'll give you some tips i've got some
tips for you uh on sudoku
regardless the great courses plus has
thousands of lectures on
almost any topic imaginable from
astrophysics to learning to speak
spanish and
new courses are coming up all the time
there's something for everyone plus
every course is presented by experts
from top universities and institutions
and you can watch or listen from your
phone or your tv with the great courses
plus
app which helps me prepare for what if
discussed
so for instance today we were talking
about what if you ate sugar
for a month straight so where do i do my
research greatcoursesplus.com
how's sugar in salt shape world history
lecture number 12 from the course
food science and the human body they got
everything here i'm glad you're doing
all the research for this because
somebody's got to peter it does make a
difference the great courses plus
is offering fans of our show this
amazing deal an entire month
of access free this limited time offer
won't last long sign up today
go to thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if don't wait go to the great
courses plus
dot com slash what if one more time it's
thegreatcoursesplus.com
now back to the show so gary you sort of
outlined what happens to the body when
you
eat sugar what uh goes on inside you
with all those
oses happening uh but what if you
only ate sugar for one month for 30 days
that's our what if this week
uh what would happen gary i can't
imagine you'd be in great shape after 30
days
if you're only eating sugar you're not
getting the vitamins you're not getting
the minerals you're not getting the
essential fatty acids that you need
you're not getting the protein that you
need
um we could debate whether or not you
need fiber in the diet but we probably
won't go there at the moment
um so i'm gonna guess that within a
reasonably short time you're gonna die
the question is can you survive
30 days yeah and we don't recommend you
try this at home
unless obviously you're part of that
experiment that gary's talking about
um gary we want to talk about a whole
bunch more especially
a big part of you know the case against
sugar was was
outlining how science was used or
misused
let's say that to be able to make the
case for sugar and against fat
uh we'll get to that on the uh on the
other side of the audio version
but this i don't know i'm just
speculating that the research and going
down this particular rabbit hole for
years
uh got you to better understand
nutrition in general
hence the case for keto your new book is
that kind of how you arrived there
it's about 90 clinical trials in process
right now
testing the ketogenic diet on virtually
every ailment you could imagine because
often it works very well when they do
these
tests on beginning with childhood
epilepsy but
you know obesity and diabetes and uh
i mean there are studies looking at it
for depression and and
the the cognitive disorders and
you name it they're there so anyway
that's sort of the
my first book good calories bad calories
in the united states looked at all of
this history and all of this bad
science and proposed this idea that the
problem with modern diets because these
british nutritionists believe is the
carbohydrate content of refined grains
and sugars
which has now kind of been accepted and
fat was benign and when you restrict the
carbs and you allow people to eat fat
now you're eating a ketogenic diet and
there's a huge movement actually
particularly in canada
there's a facebook group in canada i use
this to sort of quantify how many
physicians have bought into this so a
facebook group in canada of women
physicians who eat low carb high fat
diets
and there's about forty thousand women
physicians in canada
and there's about four thousand on this
facebook group which suggests that one
in ten
women physicians in canada alone have
embraced a way of eating that until very
recently was considered
virtually malpracticed to prescribe to
your patients
well the case for keto is being made
let's say that and
that book is available uh right now as
of what i think a couple of days ago
so if you are something if you're
somebody that's been considering a keto
diet
or certainly somebody wants to
understand just more about health and
eating
highly recommend gary's book uh the case
for keto gary can you stick around for a
few more questions
sure sure absolutely okay great amazing
if you want to hear more from
investigative science journalist and
best-selling author gary
taubs click on the link below and you
can listen to the full audio podcast of
the show if you're
already listening to us well we'll be
back right after the break
gary where can people learn more about
what you're doing right now
uh well i have a website that i don't
keep up
garyvalbs.com and every time i have a
new book that comes out my
you know friends say you've really got
to put more information on your website
um
i tweet the gary tao at gary talbs and
those would be the two primary places
you know the book is available
everywhere fine books are sold which is
amazon and as far as i can tell three
book stores that are still open
good one well for those of you who are
ready to come along with us on this
sweet ride some more click on the link
below and if
you're done with us for today well
thanks for joining us on what if
[Music]
discussed